what do I carry I carry a lot of years
that I feel that our and that's not all
bad it's partly bad
I carry a what I think I probably was
probably come through in this talk we've
had today as a kind of delight in in
doing what I do and a believer in doing
what I do along with a sadness about
doing what I do because two decades
later I'm fueling many of the questions
about war that I filled it all those
years ago and Finn law my god you know
that sort of back where we were and then
some that that feels like a tangible
burden um but I carry with me easy to
kids I mentioned and even though they're
not physically here they're they're all
around me and the person I become and
they're living inside me and I carry a
slight but palpable feel of of
obligation to do justice to the savagery
I witnessed and senselessness of it and
the sadness of it and it would that
sense of obligation is with me
especially on occasions like that like
this one we're doing trying to talk
lucidly about this stuff after you do
justice to chip my buddy and to the
ghosts of the dead Vietnamese and get
Americans and especially their mothers
and dads who are still bearing the
burden even though their kids are a long
dad I doubt they go to sleep many nights
without some poor woman in Orlando
remembering her her son of forty years
ago that she never got the
ever hold again and there that's pretty
solemn solemn obligation